So once again, as a quiz, we're going to build
a lot of this interpreter, together.
I will get started; you'll complete the rest.
We're going to write an eval_exp procedure
to interpret JavaScript arithmetic.
We're only going to handle (+), (-), and numbers for now.
Our procedure walks over a (tree) so it takes a single (tree) as argument.
Note that this is a little different from our HTML interpreter,
which took multiple (tree)s.
Remember that our (tree)s typically look like these.
It's either a tuple "number", followed by something like "5"
or maybe something like "binop", for binary operator,
with a left_child (tree),
a right_child (tree), and something like (+) in the middle.
This first part, here, is the nodetype.
We're going to extract it, by getting the zeroth element of the (tree).
If it's a "number", all I have to do is
figure out the integer value of this string.
Python allows me to do that, just by calling (int) as if it were a function--
to turn this string into an integer.
Otherwise, for us, the node might be some binary operator.
So we'll just pull out the left_child,
the operator, and the right_child
from the parts of the tuple that you already put there for us
when you did all the hard work of making the parser.
So here's what I want you to do for the quiz:
You'll need to figure out the value of the left and the right_child--
and the big hint here is recursive function call.
And then once you have those values,
you should actually do the work.
If this is a (+) binary operator, add them together.